- [Narrator] We're driving
out to Long Island today
because we found out
there's a man out there
who legally changed his
name to Santa Claus,
so, yeah.
We're gonna go interview Santa.
(playful music)
It turns out this Santa's
not so traditional.
- I drive a black Dodge pickup truck.
- [Narrator] With vanity plates.
- Oh, yes, I have vanity plates
that says SANTASLA.
- [Narrator] Before he
was Santa, he was Frank.
- I was born in Brooklyn,
but we lived here on Long Island.
I have been married 23 years now.
- [Narrator] So, how do you tell your wife
that you're changing
your name to Santa Claus?
- She said, "As long as I
don't have to change my name,
"go right ahead."
- [Narrator] Santa has been
Santa for almost two decades,
and he's good at it.
- I'm probably on,
and this is not an exaggeration,
thousands of refrigerators.
- [Narrator] He's got the laugh.
(Santa ho ho hos)
- You know, that's my Santa laugh.
- [Narrator] The suit.
- I designed my suit.
- [Narrator] But here are
some other things about Santa
that might surprise you.
- I have three tattoos on me, of me.
I'm very into zombies.
I love
barbecue.
I have a smoker that you can
fit 150 pounds of meat in.
- [Narrator] He's got this tiki hut
and above ground saltwater
pool in his backyard.
- Yes, I'm that extreme when it comes to
my idea of relaxation.
- [Narrator] So there's a
little Frank left in there,
but no question, he's fully
committed to being Santa.
- I wanna look like the poem says.
I'm the most loved person on the planet.
- [Narrator] We totally met Santa.
(playful music)